>>Hello YouTube and all internet. The question
that is being asked is at the same time very
simple and very complex. What can we do to
make the world a better place? Of course this
list is huge. We have issues of poverty, issues
of distribution,issues of growth, shortages
in various commodities and resources. So there's
no one single thing that you can do to make
the world a better place. There's a whole
collection of things. And in my mind the most
important ingredient for all the measures
that are available out there to improve the
world. The most important ingredient is cooperation.
We need to keep talking to each other. We
need to coordinate our policies,we need to
coordinate our actions, we need to coordinate
our countries. As long as you systematic concertation
process around decision makers,around groups
of countries and around institution in the
civil society,can we achieve the amount of
convergence necessary for our policies to
work all in the same direction. Thank you
very much.